hey guys welcome back to the third video
of the day today if you missed the other
two links will be in the description at
the end of the video as well as cards on
the top right if you want to get caught
up I highly suggest you watch these
videos because they're super informative
but today and final video of today to
end the trilogy of videos today is the
22 page full of patch notes I'm not
going to be reading all of these patches
because that would be an hour-and-a-half
video and I'd rather not do that so I'm
going to share with you the most
important parts if you want to read
these as well there's a link in the
description to the 22 pages full of
notes to either read by yourself or
follow along doesn't matter to me anyway
let's get started so real quick though
remember all of these patches listed are
going to be coming at the beginning of
season 3 just so you know so the first
update though is for duals on the maps
overwatching tower ruin they've removed
certain traps or move the duel to a
completely different location to prevent
Legend and salty players next up all
platforms will be getting a 1v1 ranked
duel tournament
so yes ranked is going to be introduced
in a duel setting maybe later in
Dominion but for now it's only going to
be in duel the only requirement for this
is that you have an overall rep score of
1 which everyone should have by now
unless you're a new player the anti
runaway mechanic is also being
introduced where if a player is stalling
the game by running away they have less
movement speed and they will start to
lose stamina the longer they run away
until they come back into the fight next
up to the fight tab and then this
includes the introduction to chip damage
and then the new changes to revenge
which is vile and revenge all your
attacks are unblockable your extra
health has been increased from 50 to 70
and your attacks won't be interrupted by
melee attacks such as shove like sweep
and jab and of course all the others as
well but these are just to name a few
Ubisoft is also changing multiple moves
which make which makes these have left
unlock the moves our Centurions charged
heavy Valkyries legsweep conquerors
sprint shield bash Shinobi's heavy
finishers warlords crashing charge and
Raiders Stampede charge regarding out of
stamina though warlord has no superior
block or super armor on light and heavy
attacks run out of stamina conquer and
Valcke
also don't have superior block from
light and heavies without of stamina
so basically what that means is certain
some of their attacks have superior
block or superior armor when they have
stamina but now when they're out of
stamina those properties don't exist
next up we getting the character patches
shinobi V Fleck now pushes them farther
from the enemy after deflecting them
being 2.75 meters instead of just the
original two meters law bringer and his
faint justice or her side his blind
justice can now be fainted and can be
followed by shove on hip which is the
top unblockable after parry move
basically giving him more mix of
potential the boo she's unlocked Tech
has been patched as well as warden shoe
go keys and valkyries as well and to
finish the characters orochi's wind gust
move has had his move reduced from range
which is instead of three meters it is
now 2.5 don't really see why Orochi
needed a nerf of all characters but
whatever next up there were a lot of
more feet changes but we're only going
to cover the important one once again
link in the description if you want to
read all of these smokebomb now has a
10% sprint buff when activated and
allies will be treated as if the smoke
bomb wasn't there because before the UI
wouldn't lock onto any to any of the
players regardless of what team you're
on so now if you're on the team with the
player that uses the smoke bomb you can
lock onto the enemies to the enemies
cannot lock on to you
feet cooldown now carries over between
rounds and eliminations so no more
catapult launches at the beginning of
the match just to get it back the next
round next up is the neutral color
palette can now be used along with the
attacking and defending colors along for
your better for honor fashion next up we
talk to or they talked about the gear
and to sum it up the gear will drop gear
will drop more often after matches cost
less to level up and now you will need
to hold the button down to equip armor
in the intermission instead of
accidentally equipping it when you want
it to dismantle it I feel like this is a
perfect idea because I've had this
happen to me three times just today so
this is perfect so thank God that added
this the last bits of information though
words it was an increased rep cap from
30 to 40 on characters and the new
legendary gear bore drop four characters
rep 7 or higher and the faction more you
can now place a war banner so the
now all war assets will go to that spot
instead of having to place them every
match the rest is a bunch of other
stability and small things but if you
want to read these once again in the
description and that was it so hopefully
you guys are happy with this I'm finally
happy because all the three videos that
I had to make today are finally done and
if you watched all three of these videos
tell me in the comments guys because you
guys are the real oh geez you're the
real best if you enjoyed the video
though give it a like subscribe for more
for honor content coming in the next
couple weeks including guides in game
play on the new characters thank you for
the support on all these videos as well
as yesterday's which is doing amazing
thank you guys so much if you guys do
have it or if you guys haven't seen any
of my other two videos today once again
link in the description and they'll also
be showing up right now for you guys so
you can get caught up thank you all for
the love and support on these I'll see
you guys later
peace out